[Applause]
this stretch of the M3 in Hampshire was
destined to become one of the latest
smart motorways but here and at 10 other
locations construction had already been
halted over serious safety concerns
about sacrificing the hard shoulder for
an extra Lane now those and three other
planned schemes will be scrapped for
good but Claire Mercer whose husband
Jason was killed on one says more needs
to be done I'm pleased with the news and
I'm pleased that it's gone on to cover
fruits that are being built at the
moment as well but it doesn't go far
enough it doesn't cover existing roads
and of course it's the existing roads
that are killing us because people are
being left to sit in ducks in live Lanes
Jason's van was stranded on what was
once the hard shoulder after a minor
crash it was then hit by a lorry and he
and another man died
but so have many others
during his leadership campaign Rishi
sunak vowed to ban all-new smart
motorways if he was elected and now as
prime minister he says he's making good
on that promise in recognition of the
lack of public confidence as well as
Financial pressures it's set to save
around a billion pounds
but for Claire it's proof it's all about
money I think it's very cynical of the
government to be motivated by the
budgetary sides of it you know when we
were saying you know this is human lives
this is costing human lives that for
four years they've not been interested
the decision to suspend construction was
made in January last year to allow time
for safety data to be collected motoring
groups have welcomed the decision to
scrap it all together
37 of breakdowns are in a live Lane if
you're broken down by Flame you're
dependent on the technology spotting you
you're dependent on a red X coming up
you're dependent on other cars abiding
by that Red X
those are too many risks to take
work is continuing to build 150
emergency areas on the Smart Road
schemes already in action they make up
10 percent of the country's Motorway
Network while that's the case
campaigning will continue
Emma birchley Sky News